thrill soda hired a marketing company to
help them promote their brand against
yummy cola the company gathered the
following data about consumers
preference of a soda so they have year
by year percentage of respondents who
preferred yummy cola percentage of
respondents who perform who prefer
thrill cola and then these are people
who had no preference so in 2006 80
percent liked yummy only 12 percent
liked thrill and 8 percent didn't like
either one or didn't have any preference
and so actually just from here you see
that many many more people liked yummy
cola than thrill coal actually every
year over here so thrill cola definitely
has something they have an uphill battle
but then they said the advertising
company created the following two graphs
to promote thrill soda and so let's see
what's happening over here so and let's
think about whether this is misleading
or not
so if we look at this graph over here in
2006 sure enough 80 percent liked yummy
cola than 2007 76 percent then it keeps
going then 77 percent then 73 percent
then 73 and 68. so this is actually
accurate data it actually represents the
data that's given that's given right
over here i'll do it in the same it
actually represents this data very
faithfully then right over here if we
look at this chart percentage of people
who prefer thrill soda so over here in
2006 12 percent prefer
thrill soda 2006 12 percent 2007 19
2008 19 then we go up to 20 21 and 25.
so the graphs are actually accurate
they're not lying these are actually the
data points of the percentage who prefer
thrill soda
now what's misleading is if someone were
to just look at these two graphs without
actually looking at the scales over here
they'll see two things they'll say oh
look you see a declining trend and
that's what line graphs are good for for
seeing trends they say look i see a
declining trend in the number of in the
percentage of people who prefer yummy
cola and i see this increasing trend in
the percentage of people who prefer
thrill call and that's true they have a
declining trend here and you have an
increasing trend here but what's
misleading here is the way that they've
plotted the scales these scales are not
the same so when you look at this you
say not only is there an increasing
trend of people who prefer drill soda
but the way they set up the scale that
it looks like the trend is above it
looks like if you look your the human
brain is tempted to compare these and
they say look not only is this an upward
trend but it's above this trend right
over here even in 2006 this data point
looks higher than than these data points
right over here but the reality is is
that it's only because the scale is
distorted and this is the oldest trick
in the book when plotting line graphs it
all depends on the scale so this just
looks good because they used this scale
that went from 0 to 30 as opposed to 0
100. the more
the better thing to do or the more
genuine thing to do or the more honest
thing to do would have actually been to
plot them on the same graph although if
they did that that wouldn't have painted
a very good picture for thrill soda so
if we bought it on the same graph the
real soda let's try that out so in 2006
12 and actually this is even worse you
could actually wouldn't even be able to
plot thrill sold on this graph because
they started this graph right over here
at 50 percent they didn't even start it
at zero percent so you actually would
not even be able to plot thrill sold on
this graph if you did
you would have to extend this graph all
the way down
so you would have to extend this graph
all the way down to
you know so this would have to be 40
this would be 30 you this would be 20
this would be 10
and then or down all the way over here
would be zero percent and then the
thrill soda graph would be all the way
down here so it was like 12 percent and
it goes all the way up to like 25
percent so the thrill soda so it would
have looked something like this
the graph would have looked something
like this
which is nowhere near if you if you
plotted these on the same thing on the
same scale on the same graph then it
would have still been pretty obvious
that a lot more people even though the
trend is downward a lot more people
prefer you prefer yummy cola to to
thrill cola so there's two very
disingenuous things going on over here
one is the actual scale for this amount
of distance on this scale they represent
10 so whatever the gain is it looks like
it's a huge gain and over here that same
amount they're actually representing a
larger amount they're representing
closer to 15 or 16 percent and then the
main thing is they started the scale
here at 50 so they're not showing how
many people really prefer how how large
eighty percent or even seventy percent
really is and over here they start at
zero and they just have a larger scale
so it makes it look like out the gate a
lot of people prefer or comparable
amount of people prefer thrill and that
the trend is up but the reality is still
way more people prefer yummy cola so
this was a little bit
actually very very not so honest way of
representing the data
or i guess you say they're
misrepresenting the data